hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt ich habe irgendwann aufgehört
zu zählen wie oft ihr euch dieses video
gewünscht habt heute machen wir nämlich
airbag gebe nein spaß die kurshausse
creme torte aus einkommen und gefallen
heute sogar eine kleine premiere denn
ich koche das erste mal seit ewigkeiten
aus meiner eigenen küche look at the
speed week has everything der region die
tür wie man auch und zu machen kann und
tassen und so da die kokosnuss creme
tortilla ein amerikanisches rezept ist
und eigentlich ein coconut kripo ist
brauchen wir eine piper ist sie nicht
wunderschön und verstaubt und ich habe
noch etwas anderes besorgt kleine mini
gipfel doch nach einem amerikanischen
rezept und amerikanische rezepte werden
immer in cups angegeben und weil man
sich dann so dumm und dämlich messen
musste habe ich mir ein set cups geholt
die caps kannst du natürlich auch als bh
tragen
zuerst fahren wir mit der kruste an denn
wie beim käse kuchen aus deutschland hat
der american pie immer so eine kruste in
die dann die füllung reinkommen perfekt
in amerika oder in den usa kannst du
diese brüssel als fertigen teil kaufen
musste ihn dann nur aus leben hier in
deutschland lägen noch ganz viel wert
auf handarbeit die kruste zu machen ist
zum glück ganz einfach wir brauchen nur
mehl salz ungehörtes pflanzenfett und
wasser zuerst braucht mit zwei cups mail
an nummer zwei dann einen tief berührt
und denkt dann wenn ein bisschen zu
wenig salz genommen haben nimmt einfach
ein bisschen mehr salz
und langsam verstehe ich das mit den
caps nicht denn ich brauche zwei drittel
caps von butter
ich stand mir nur das um gehärtete
pflanzenfett muss jetzt klein gehackt
werden damit man es gut leben kann
oder macht einfach so ein margarine auf
eure margarine skulptur kommt jetzt auch
in die schüssel
jetzt brauchen wir noch fünf bis sieben
takers punkten das wird jetzt alles
schön zusammengemixt bist wie ein tiger
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die hand drei fühlt sich gar
nicht mal so schlecht an dir auf ein
bisschen tykwer ich sag ja foto deutsche
handarbeit
naja gut deutsch polnische italienische
handarbeit dem gut durchgeknetet packen
wir dann auf ein brett und rollen ihn
aus der lässt sich richtig gut aus
rollen ich glaube das liegt an dem um
gehärteten pflanzenfett weil bei den
kürbis pasteten gegen das ja überhaupt
nicht da war es ja krümelig und sonstwas
und der ist richtig schnell
[Musik]
er ist richtig gut der ist so weich und
macht können rechnungen unser teil kommt
hier sind die plattform eigenlob stinkt
ja ein bisschen aber cobra wega das
geworden ist ich bin super mit unserer
zeit auch schön flach bleibt pieksen wir
jetzt noch mit einer gabel löcher rein
er kommt jetzt für der kommt es bei 407
tief auf die gries in die orden am
kitzbüheler also 190 grad bis das ding
brown ist gute erklärung erst fertig und
so kruste muss jetzt gut abkühlen und in
der zeit machen wir die creme für die
creme brauchen wir jetzt ein paar mehr
zutaten zuerst mixen wir einen halben
kopf zucker und einen pickup
speisestärke in eine schüssel ist
überhaupt richtiges geheime zutat meldet
ist man gut miteinander verrührt und
jetzt brauchen wir vier eigene wir
trennen weiß von gott das kirchenbuch
slang dran mülltrennung das würde den
bio drittel sind jetzt umso eigelbe war
und jetzt kommt da noch half and half
cream rein dafür in deutschland aber
keiner half and half cream haben nehme
ich sahne und milch und mache half und
habe im rezept steht wir brauchen zwei
cups hafen traf also nämlich ein cup
milch und einen cup sahne und das müssen
wir jetzt miteinander verrühren
so ein richtig sahnige song let kommt
daraus jetzt kommt die große vereinigung
speisestärke zucker und sahne und das
muss natürlich auch durch gemixt werden
für den nächsten schritt müssen wir
einmal in diese richtung wandern ist das
nicht cool
oh mein gott es ist so cool müssen
unsere creme nämlich für eine minute
aufkochen und da steht penn und pen
heißt doch fahne schweiz pennig kugeln
weil ich weiß dass bei den fun heißt und
jetzt bewundert allem einen drauf und ab
geht die luzie und unsere flüssigkeit
musste jetzt rein bis zum fenster
dunst seht ihr ja ruhig und es gibt drei
tables butter drin steht für ein tier
dafür vinyl extrakt rein aber weil ich
keinen werden extrakt habe ich jetzt
dieses und vanille
die ist sogar somit verhülle schon es
wäre ja keine cookies cream torte wenn
er nicht kokosnuss mit drin wer ein
bisschen kräfte bei den großen
denkt dran immer zwischendurch
nachhinein cup kokosnuss bloggen und das
wird jetzt auch gemixt creme müssen
unbedingt probieren
oh mein gott ich habe wirklich immer
gedacht dass vanille pudding zu machen
so schwer ist aber das ist super läuft
es gut ich habe vanillepudding gemacht
und keiner star sieht das so kinder wie
reisen jetzt mal wieder eben rüber zu
sehen unsere kosten und unseren pudding
und führen sie zusammen
es ist so einer der momente wo ich mir
wünschen würde dass man gerüchte schon
über das internet übertragen könnte es
riecht so gut und so krebs jetzt
abgekühlt und hart und jetzt kommt die
sahen also die lecker zusammen
schichtung drauf für die letzte schicht
brauchen wir zwei cups sahne und nummer
zwei und dann müssen wir aus der
flüssigen eine feste seinem 8
wir haben wenig zu der saane kommt jetzt
natürlich auch noch eine dritte kampf
zucker fett und zucker und 1 teelöffel
vanille extrakt so und das rühren wir
jetzt vorsichtig noch mit rein
der grosse moment ist gekommen um mein
gott das darf ich euch vorstellen die
kokosnuss creme torte aus
damit man auch weiß was drin steckt auch
ein paar kokosraspeln oben drüber geht
kokosraspeln schaut euch das an wie
lecker und jetzt stellen wir uns
natürlich wieder der allerwichtigsten
frage wie schmeckt die kokosnuss creme
torte auf ein karger ich freue mich so
dass mein gott schmeckt so gut weil ich
meine dass es mit der ganzen sahne und
so überhaupt nicht gut für den körper
aber manchmal muss man sich auch was
können und wenn man sich was könnte dann
ist es die kokosnuss kreditausfall ist
diese koste ja überhaupt nicht süß
sondern eher müssen salzig und das ist
so geil die kombination mit dem ganzen
süßen um brauchen mit dem seil ziehen
ich verlinke ich war das rezept das ist
benutzt habe und bin in der infobox da
könnt ihr mal nachschauen wenn ihr es
nachmachen möchte wie immer hofft
natürlich hat diese folge wie schmeckt
gefallen und wenn ja das zeigt dass wir
mit einem daumen nach oben und wenn ihr
weitere rezeptvorschläge habt aus filmen
und serien runter damit in die
kommentare und jetzt könnt ihr nicht
mehr kokosnuss cremt orte schreiben
hh jetzt müsst ihr etwas neues ausdenken
denn ich habe sie gemacht die kokosnuss
krieg heute aus alkali und jetzt gute
nacht nicht gute nacht bis dann kann ich
auch wenn prof